hmm okay everybody major major Game of
Thrones spoilers here for the last five
seasons of Game of Thrones we've
understood the show to be a linear
storyline one thing leads to another
thing to another thing you get the idea
but in the past few episodes that's
totally changed in his training with the
three-eyed Raven bran stark has learned
how to travel through time in dreamlike
visions and that makes Game of Thrones
one of a whole lot of works of fiction
that have experimented with time travel
scientists have debunked the idea that
we never be able to travel into the past
but that hasn't stopped physicist from
theorizing how it would work logically
this is sort of the Internet's go-to
explainer on how time travel works in
fiction my name is Harrison Densmore and
I'm a graphic designer in writer
I created this infographic about seven
years ago you can generally break down
time-traveling movies into one of three
different styles
there's the multiverse timeline the
dynamic timeline and the fixed timeline
in a multiverse timeline there are an
infinite number of parallel universes
any time travel immediately creates a
new timeline and the traveler can do
just about anything
only that timeline is affected kill your
grandfather and you'll have just created
a new universe where you don't exist
this is what you see with Terminator 2
in Terminator 3 Rick and Morty Doctor
Who and the 2009 Star Trek and then
there's what he calls the dynamic
timeline where altered events in the
past have a real impact on the present
go back and try to kill your grandfather
here and you create a paradox a logical
contradiction if you time-traveled to
kill your grandfather you wouldn't exist
in the future to travel back in time to
kill your grandfather and you can see
the idea of a dynamic timeline present
in Back to the Future it doesn't really
make sense because the traveler is
returning to a present day that he
wouldn't actually exist in then there's
the fixed timeline in a fixed timeline
when a person travels back in time they
can't change the future that they just
left this is the version that you see in
the prisoner of azkaban
saving your life or 12 monkeys
everything that they do just confirms
the present that they left try to kill
your grandfather here and you'll
inevitably fail you can't change the
past
and it seems like this is how Game of
Thrones interprets the idea it all
starts with this moment right here when
brain is watching a young version of his
late father because Ned Stark turns
around seemingly in response to Brad's
voice it seems like bran might be able
to change the past so when the Raven
says this the past is always rooted to
the English drama it sounds like he's
not telling the truth clearly if bran
was able to get his father to react to
his voice then it seems like he has the
power to change the past right but what
happens to Hodor dispels this idea when
Brandon takes control of his body in the
present while also observing him in the
past he creates a psychic link between
past and present that destroys her
daughter's mind so brand created Hodor
Hodor as we've always known him on the
show and that could mean that bran can't
affect the past but only in ways that
lead to outcomes that we already see in
the present brains powers seem to
operate in what's called a closed
timelike curve in mathematical physics
and what that means is that all
time-travel is consistent with its
starting point
every change he creates is already true
in his present world and that's
different from Back to the Future where
actions in the past produce a new
different future the Game of Thrones
approach to the theory seems to follow
something called the Novikov
self-consistency principle it's a
physics conjecture that assumes a single
timeline sitting that if there is an
event that would cause a paradox then
the probability of that event is zero in
1990 the Russian physicist Igor
dmitriyevich Novikov teamed up with
researchers from Caltech to write a
paper in which they argued that there
are no unresolvable paradoxes in the
singular timeline framework that means
that no matter what a theoretical time
traveler does they could never succeed
to create a situation that doesn't work
logically they would never be able to
succeed in killing the grandfather for
example and that's basically what
appears to be happening in Game of
Thrones it seems like brand can interact
with the past but only in ways that
confirm the existing present reality
unfortunately for brand that means that
he can't change any of the bad things
that have happened to
but it opens up the possibility that he
could be the source behind a lot of
major events the internet already has a
lot of theories he could turn out to be
the voices in the mad king's head or
partly responsible for the creation of
the wall itself and that would make him
the most important character in the
whole story for all we know he could be
orchestrating everything we've seen in
the show so far